[Music]  [Applause]  first time at the El Royale you have the  option to stay in either California or  Nevada I always want to stay in the  honeymoon suite even though I'm not  currently on my honeymoon I got a job  singing arena tomorrow don't pay nothing  but a thing ends then this is not a  place for a priest father you shouldn't  be here  it's a little too quiet in here it gives  me a willies  [Music]  they're just too big problem  you watch me I only want to they tell me  to watch these legs  management did you think you could just  take this mind I wouldn't come a hug no  I figured you would  [Music]  he lost father can I confess something  to you I'm not really a priest  it's a game it all starts with a simple  choice would you mind opening the door  which cider you want right wrong God or  no God red or black  everybody  she had happened to get the whiskey  [Music]  [Music]  you